[Music]
foreign
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Tuesday May 30th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
you might know clear the secure identity
company from the airport it has those
frustratingly short lines of people just
scanning their faces and their eyes in a
pod to confirm their identity while the
rest of us stand in what can feel like a
never-ending security line but the CEO
of clear Karen seidman Becker wants to
take the company in a whole new
Direction at this year's Wall Street
Journal future of everything Festival
she spoke with our Tech columnist
Christopher Mims about her plans here
are highlights from their conversation
so like five ten years from now where am
I actually gonna use Clear well it's
where you're using it today right so
you're using it to check in at a hotel
as opposed to going to the front so I'll
just go in and they'll look at my face
yes I mean the computer will look at my
face actually the phone will look at
your face you'll do it within their app
okay or you're doing it to replace the
clipboard at a hospital as opposed to
filling out all those forms so my actual
medical records will be linked yes and
your insurance card and your copay or
you're using it to get into a sports
Stadium or you're using it to buy a beer
because you're over 21 and your credit
card so you're doing that now right
there's NFL stadiums I can go to now and
get that and buy a beer with my face Las
Vegas of course is the right place to
start that but when you think about it
people have been carrying around wallets
for decades full of cards to prove who
they are and what they have access to
and so our vision is to fuse those cards
to your Biometrics your face your
fingerprint your eyes your voice and
because identity is foundational and you
start to see that right we could riffen
everything to be clear not just uh in
the real world but online too so you you
have this new thing where I can verify
through my phone who I am for LinkedIn
um I mean where else could I use this
online to verify I am who I say I am
well let's talk about our partnership
with LinkedIn for a minute there was a
recent report 55 of the people said they
lied on their resume so it is a real
problem I just got back last night from
LA from the milking conference and there
was a ton of conversation about talent
and how hard it is to recruit talent and
to retain Talent LinkedIn is the source
of Truth for that Talent before you meet
someone you go on their LinkedIn all the
people I was meeting in La that is the
source of truth I wouldn't suggest that
it's Wikipedia or something like that so
having it be accurate and having it be
easy why would you be re-verifying where
you went to college every time like that
makes no sense so would this like
prevent like a future like George Santos
type scenario like if Congress bothered
to check LinkedIn and they're like okay
I do believe go back to 55 percent of
the people lying on their resumes that
George Santos is not alone and that that
would show that we have a real world
problem that has real consequences wow
just to go back to your hotel example
because I really like that one and I
could see that application happening in
a lot of different places I mean could I
eventually use this to you know buy
things in a store
yes so I would be I would like have
clear it would be integrated with my
phone somehow and it would just be like
the Amazon go experience I just walk out
absolutely um you know we talked about
the consumerization of Biometrics and
our vision of that starting in 2010 it
was really only in the defense area and
we believed it was going to be
consumerized all these companies
starting to engage with it would reflect
that when you go to CVS and you do
self-checkout and you buy Sudafed they
stop you and someone comes over and asks
for your driver's license because you
have to be over 18. but clear is going
to make it much easier for me to buy all
the Sudafed I want not only will we but
we oh well I don't know about Mass
Sudafed but but
when you look at what is happening
online gaming and alcohol delivery and
buying Mass Sudafed right it's all
founded in identity and something about
you in some places it's your age in some
places it might be your employment or
your health care co-pay and so
absolutely there's when you look at how
many times you take out cards in your
every day life that's identity so I feel
like we we we're in a different era you
know there was a time when the just the
idea of Biometrics sort of frightened
people and Apple and Samsung and others
have done a lot to normalize that
um but let's talk about like the Privacy
and the data part of this because you
know I I always just kind of Imagine
like the anonymous Twitter critic when I
want to go to like what is the kind of
the the most common critique of your
business model going to be and I imagine
them saying hey you know you started out
as a public private partnership with the
Department of Homeland Security why how
do I trust you and how do I know that
this isn't just a big CIA op to funnel
all of Americans data to the NSA or
something so we started in the hardest
Place Aviation where identity is
Paramount we started as a partnership
with the Department Homeland Security as
a qualified anti-terrorism technology so
privacy and data security was part of
our ethos from day one and as part of
our culture and part of the DNA of our
company I also think it's really
important for all companies today
everyone has data so being really
transparent about how you use the data
what do you do purging the data securing
the data and really bringing that trust
to your consumers it's their data but to
be clear any company that possesses data
now there is some tension between the
needs of the individual for privacy and
the needs of say law enforcement for
data so your Google your Apple they
publish privacy reports every year they
say these are the number of times we
handed over data and you know probably a
lot of them are Justified like there was
some terrible crime that was in progress
and and you know somebody needed a
warrant in order to get that data you
know other companies are looser with it
right like we saw a recent report that
Twitter's been a lot looser with just
giving data to any government that asks
for it do you have that that kind of
disclosure where you're like this is how
many times we've had to turn over data
are you going to have to start creating
that we have been very transparent so
here's what we say and we put it it all
bold all caps is you know bottom line up
front at the beginning so people don't
have to scroll down through the whole
privacy policy which is we do not sell
or share data you join clear in order to
have your data secured in exchange for
frictionless experiences everything that
we do is opt-in and I think that is so
important and then when you do opt-in we
are telling you exactly the Micro Data
that you would be sharing for instance
with Avis in order to skip the checkout
desk we say you're sharing that you're
over 25 you're sharing your you know
credit card whatever it is exactly that
you're sharing
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]